justin krueger doit justifier la raison
pour laquelle elle envoyait l'argent qui
est bien avec l'épée comme italie brésil
et l'iran
oui le canada verse des fonds à des pays
développés une fois rendu là bas
à quoi sert l'argent canadien commençons
par l'italie le gouvernement canadien a
bien envoyé deux millions de dollars aux
italiens il s'agissait d'une aide
d'urgence après le tremblement terre de
2016 qui a fait près de 300 morts au
brésil l'inde canadienne sert entre
autres à financer des projets de
recherche sur les changements
climatiques et des études sur le virus
du zii cote en iran les fonds canadiens
ont par exemple servi à s'assurer que
l'iran respecte ses engagements en
matière de non prolifération nucléaire
depuis les quatre dernières années on a
fait énormément d'investissement cela
dit en matière d'international le canada
est encore bien loin des objectifs fixés
par l'onu
le canada devrait consacrer 0,7 pour
cent de son revenu national brut à
l'aide internationale mais en 2018
le pays ni consacré que 0,28 pour ça
cependant si un jour scheer sabre comme
promis le quart des fonds dédiés à
l'aide étrangère et les budgets vont
baisser à des niveaux qu'on n'a pas vue
depuis 1965